i know
uh
[Music]
you'll use the mask
i was at five now i'm at 4-7
it's cool
um
um
yep
hello
uh
um
oh
uh
[Music]
um
okay
ready
oh
um
um
two minute warning on the press briefing
thank you
good afternoon how are we good thanks
how are you
uh
yes
hi everyone good afternoon
well uh we are very excited that later
today
the president will sign an executive
order that takes a whole of government
approach to securing critical
u.s supply chains ensuring we can
withstand crises and
create good-paying jobs in the process
the coven 19 pandemic
has underlined the need for resilient
supply chains and robust domestic
manufacturing
so all americans have access to
essential goods and services in times of
crisis
the eo will direct immediate 100-day
reviews of supply chains for critical
products that go into everything from
phones to pharmaceuticals it will also
direct reviews of industrial-based
sectors including defense
public health and biological
preparedness information and
communications technology transportation
energy and food production this is an
issue with strong bipartisan support
and later this afternoon the president
will meet with a bipartisan group of
house and senate members
to discuss supply chain resilience and
the need to work together and
strengthening it
we'll provide you all a list of that
later this afternoon as it's finalized
uh joining us today to talk through the
details of the executive
order our deputy director of the
national economic council
samira fazili i may have butchered your
last name as
mine is butchered sometimes i'll keep
working on it and senior director of
international economics and
competitiveness at the nsc
peter harrell thank you for joining us
um and they will take
we'll see if we have time to take a
couple questions dave good reason they
have to go see the president shortly
okay
thank you very much uh jan and thanks to
all of you it's a
privilege for me to be here um as jen
said this afternoon the president will
sign an executive order that takes a
critical step in ensuring that america's
supply chains can withstand any crisis
as well as supporting jobs across the
country last year
in the early months of the pandemic
frontline healthcare workers couldn't
find the masks gloves
and ppe that they needed to keep
themselves safe as they treated covet 19
patients
today automotive automakers across the
country are having to take workers off
factory lines
because they can't get access to enough
computer chips to maintain full
production
last july president biden committed that
as president
he would direct his administration to
take a comprehensive approach to
securing america's supply chains
he said then and he will reiterate later
today that america should never face
shortages of critical products and times
of crisis
our supply chain should not be
vulnerable to manipulation by competitor
nations
the eo that the president will sign
later today formally launches the
initiative
president biden committed to last year
to build strong and resilient supply
chains this is the first whole of
government approach to promoting the
resilience of america's supply chains
from pharmaceuticals to foods
we are going to get out of the business
of reacting to supply chain crises as
they arise
and get into the business of preventing
future supply chain problems
as jen said the eo the president will
sign will direct immediate 100-day
reviews of supply chains for four
critical products
computer chips for everything from cars
to phones
large capacity batteries such as those
used in electric cars
cars so that america leads in making
next generation electric vehicles
pharmaceuticals and active
pharmaceutical ingredients the key
ingredients to american medicines
and critical minerals and strategic
materials such as rare earth minerals
that are essential to american industry
and to america's defense base
the eo will also direct six sector
specific reviews to be completed within
one year of today
to be focused on defense public health
and biological preparedness
information and communications
technology transportation
energy and food production these
sectoral reviews will be modeled after
the process
that the defense department uses to
regularly evaluate and
strengthen america's defense and
industrial base
make no mistake we are not simply
planning to order up reports we are
going to be taking
actions to close gaps as we identify
them
just as we have been working with
industry in recent weeks to ensure that
u.s
automobile manufacturers have the parts
they need
to keep making cars here in america but
we expect that by taking
this type of comprehensive approach to
supply chain resilience
we'll be able to strengthen our supply
chains for the long term
and with that i'm happy to turn this
over to my friend and colleague samira
thank you peter creating more
resilient supply chains is an
opportunity for our country to come
together
to create well-paying jobs for workers
across our country
that is why today's action reinforces
the president's overarching commitment
to help our country build back better we
know that even before the coveted crisis
the economy was not working for most
americans
worker pay was too low many families
could not make ends meet
many of the jobs that served as the
heart of the middle class
had been lost due to changes in both
technology and the structure of the
global economy
disruption is inevitable but over the
past few years we have moved from crisis
to crisis when some essential product
was suddenly in short supply
what we need is a capacity to respond
quickly when hit by a challenge
this executive order moves the whole
government towards being more prepared
these sector specific reviews that the
president orders today
we're going to be asking agencies to do
the following they're going to review
risks and supply chains and in our
domestic industrial base
they're going to think broadly about
risk there's climate risk and
geopolitical risk
but there's also risk in not having
enough workers ready to meet the needs
of that sector
or enough factories or the right
equipment to make a good
or retool a shift to shift to a new
spike in demand for an essential good
they're going to be recommending actions
to improve resiliency
in some instances that action might be
the data that government
can publish and so the private sector
can plan
and mobilize and take action but in
other instances we have levels like
procurement authority that we can use to
support stockpiling or support some
level of domestic production
we are also going to be looking for
opportunities to work with congress to
give us more tools
so that we can improve our preparedness
and today's conversation with members of
congress is going to be
part of an ongoing conversation we've
been having with them on this
finally a big part of this executive
order is consultation with stakeholders
and experts
we are going to be reaching out to talk
to the american people government action
alone will not solve
complex supply chain challenges this is
going to be broad
engagement broad conversations that will
include business
labor local communities academia this
work is going to require a new
commitment to public-private
partnerships
and we need all voices at that table to
help us design those partnerships
this is a real opportunity to invest in
the future of america and build on our
nation's strengths
there are opportunities for small
business development to help diversify
supplier networks and alleviate the risk
of too big to fail companies
in the supply chains for critical goods
there are opportunities to improve
worker readiness and training
so they have the skills needed to ramp
up research production or distribution
of a critical good
and there are opportunities to bring
more jobs to communities around the
country
including communities of color to
leverage the ingenuity and grit of the
american
people this is going to leverage u.s
scientific leadership it's going to
further advance our research and
development prowess
it will do so while also recognizing
that our ability to maintain our
innovative edge
in research requires us to invest in
both research and manufacturing in
communities across
america because when you pair thinkers
and doers that's how you create the
technologies and products that help us
tackle tomorrow's challenges i want to
reiterate what my colleagues have said
this work is not going to be about
america going it alone
the answer to these weaknesses is not
always to be to ramp up domestic
production
we know these vulnerabilities affect not
just american households it's a global
problem
for in some of these supply chains we
are committed to working with partners
and allies to reduce these
vulnerabilities
that are affecting all of us the work
ahead
builds upon america's historic legacy of
making strategic investments in our
future
that lay the foundation for broad-based
economic growth
smart investments in research
manufacturing
domestic capacity and our workforce has
in the past
unleashed decades of economic expansion
and an expansion that raised wages and
living standards for
american families across the country we
can and should
build upon that legacy and that is how
we will approach this supply chain work
this problem was decades in the making
we can solve it by making smart
investments that are long-term in nature
that reach families and workers in all
of america thank you
okay go ahead thanks jen
um presidents for decades have been
promising
to create factory jobs we're we've got
about 12.2 million factory jobs that's
down from 17 billion and 2
000. how many jobs do you think this
initiative can create
and what are your metrics of success
i think we think it's important to have
a broad lens and broad view
on how you measure the jobs and the job
creation in the manufacturing space
because manufacturing is not usu doesn't
must support and create
jobs in the manufacturing sector there
are broad spillover effects that it has
there are going to be r d jobs here
research jobs here there's going to be
jobs
in the kind of supplier networks in the
services industry so
i think it's we have to start tracking
and understanding
that manufacturing's contributions to
our economy can't just be
narrowly counted in that way should i
suggest
better um when you talk about
incentivizing and funding
on the budget that you're the upcoming
budget do you think that you will
propose some sort of federal
funding to help increase the supply of
semiconductors
you know we are still in the process of
formulating the budget so at this time
i'm not able to talk in specifics about
the budget proposal
but what i would say is we are looking
forward to talking with members of
congress about what more we can do in
partnership with them
to give us the funds we need
just like a step back for um you know
for a moment obviously we're talking
about
um multiple different supply chains here
and i think that the
solutions we will be proposing and
implementing will vary a little bit
by supply chain you know supply chain
for semiconductors obviously looks quite
different from the supply chain
for rare earths so i think what you're
going to see is us come forward with a
comprehensive
suite of recommendations that will be
tailored for each of the different
critical goods that we are looking at
in general across the board we're
expecting
we'll be using a mix of incentives to
encourage
production here looking at ways to
ensure their surge capacity
available for things that might need to
be ramped up quickly stockpiling
working with our allies and partners to
make sure that we have
you know cross-border open flows with
our allies and partners
where we might collectively need to take
some action so i think we're really
going to be looking at a range of
different tools here
not just any um particular uh single
tool
defense production act is there would
you think that the white house would
consider
using the defense production act for
specifically for the semiconductors
um you know i don't think we're here to
talk about how we would use the dpa
on any particular supply chain at this
point but clearly
um as we look at making resilient uh
supply chains across the board
um all tools are on the table for this
administration and then on taiwan
can you say how has taiwan reacted to
some of your
requests for assistance on this have
they been receptive to your
pleas for help on boosting the supplies
of the chips
um i don't want to get into the nuances
of specific diplomatic
conversations we have had clearly taiwan
is an important partner of the united
states and we've had constructive
conversations with them
i'm sorry we have to let them go but i
know there's a lot of interest in this
and well we can do follow-up questions
afterwards as well but thank you both so
much for joining us at the briefing and
you're welcome back any time thank you
okay i just have a couple
of additional items at the top
uh as you heard in our covid public
health briefing just a few minutes ago
starting next month we will begin to
deliver millions of mass to food banks
and community health centers around the
country
these are two nationwide networks that
disproportionately serve
hard-hit populations today many
low-income americans still lack access
to this basic protection
that's why we think taking this
thoughtful and targeted action
to keep americans safe we will deliver
more than 25 million masks
across the country these mass will be
available at homes oh i'm sorry at more
than
300 community health centers and around
60 000
food pantries any american who needs a
mask will be able to walk into these
health centers
or food pantries and pick up a high
quality american-made mask
that is consistent with cdc guidance
this program is made possible through
existing
funding at hhs and with this action we
are hoping to level the playing field
giving
vulnerable populations quality
well-fitting masks a couple other things
i know
lots going on today i wanted to make
sure you saw a letter released this
morning by over 160
ceos representing some of america's
biggest and most represented company
respected companies calling on congress
to act on the
president's rescue plan there is growing
consensus across the country
for this package and that's reflected in
showing a bipartisan majority of
americans
back it as the more than 160 business
leaders put in this their letter to
congressional leaders
previous federal leaf measures have been
essential but more must be done to put
the country on a trajectory for a strong
and durable
recovery also a winter storm update
temperatures are back within normal
ranges for this time of year across the
states that have been
impacted by the storm that's of course
good news but water system outages
and boil water advisories although
improving remain an ongoing issue across
the region requiring additional federal
support
uh delayed shipments of 19 vaccine doses
are anticipated to be filled in the
coming days as we noted
last week and vaccination sites have
reopened and are doubling up
appointments to accommodate those
cancelled
last week all major airports are open
all rail carriers have returned to
normal operations
interstate and state highways are open
transit agencies are returning to normal
operations
and ports are operating under normal
circumstances
federal assistance continues we noted
the additional 31 counties yesterday and
of course
we'll continue to consider additional
requests moving forward
finally to remain transparent with you
and the american people we wanted to
share that the president
tested negative for covid 19 on monday
we will
venture to provide this update the
following day in the future
but this is part of our regular coveted
safety protocols that i mentioned a
couple of weeks ago
the entire white house complex as you
know continues to adhere to strict
math squaring social distancing and
other mitigation strategies
okay sorry a few things at the top go
ahead thanks jen uh
on the masks uh any sense of why the
white house is using cloth masks instead
of n95s
which are also made in america we have
supplies and do you have a list of
manufacturers
of the masks sure well i would say that
these macs are
these masks are all uh adhere to cdc
guidelines and certainly they meet those
requirements set by our federal standard
and tell me your second question again
uh a list of the manufacturers of the
masks
i don't have a list of those i can see
if there's more details we can provide
okay and then separately vladimir putin
said today
that russia's going to redouble its
efforts on opposing
foreign powers we say is basically
trying to
undermine russia does the white house
believe that tensions with russia
are increasing well we believe that
certainly
over the last um several years there
have been more concerning steps that
have been taken
by vladimir putin and by members of the
kremlin as the president has expressed
and expressed during the campaign
and that is why he asked his national
security team
to launch a process of looking into
uh not only uh hacking uh reports of
hacking around the 2020 election but
also
uh the bounties on our troops that was
of concern of course the solar winds
hack
and to take a close look at that so we
have our own assessment
as you know the president also spoke
with president putin just maybe two
weeks ago
and did not hold back in expressing his
concerns about the actions
of his government but we are letting
that process see itself through
as i noted yesterday it will be weeks
not months before it's concluded and we
have more details about our response
good thank you um so i just wanted to
see if you could confirm
that the president is speaking with king
salman of saudi arabia today
um and if he'll do that in advance of
the report on khashoggi
well as we've noted in the past we
remain committed to
releasing through the dni of course an
unclassified report
uh on that we expect to happen soon i
don't have an
updated timeline for you on that i know
there were also reports on a
proposed call we also expect that to
happen soon we're still in the process
of scheduling when that that will happen
what are they going to be talking about
in that call well uh
i'll well when we have the call and the
president has the call i'm sure we'll do
a readout of it
of course we've had engagements at many
levels with the saudis to date but we'll
do a readout once we conclude the call
you have a status update on uh nira
tandon with all of the delays on capitol
hill as far as her
uh confirmation and tell me more about
what you mean by that
an update as far as whether you're going
to withdraw that name
um it doesn't seem like the votes are
there for her at this point
well let me first state that uh as the
president uh repeated yesterday uh we're
fighting for her nomination
and she and our team remain in close
contact and
close touch with senators and key
constituency groups
she's an expert whose qualifications are
critical during this time of an
unprecedented crisis
and she has rolled up her sleeves she's
very engaged in doing outreach to
senators to members on the hill
answering any questions
they have and offering to do that and
we're doing the same i know there was an
announcement
about a delay of a confirmation vote
today and they put out a statement
uh to make clear that of course they're
going to do due diligence as are we
to continue that outreach and continue
to fight for her nomination followed him
go ahead jen thank you how big of a
setback
does the white house view the fact that
the senate committees have delayed
the vote on her confirmation to be well
again they put out the a statement from
the leadership of the committee
conveying clearly that uh they wanted to
continue to do work to build support for
her nomination
as a setback to near attendance
confirmation i i wouldn't put it in
those terms
i think we are committed to uh
continuing to fight for all of our
nominees
continuing to do the outreach needed to
answer questions to address concerns
anyone has to reiterate
uh the qualifications of all the
nominees that the president uh has put
forward and
to do due diligence in fighting for the
for the team he's nominated even if she
is
confirmed does it undercut the
president's
budget agenda to have this confirmation
delayed
well as i noted a couple of times here
but it's worth repeating
nero tandon has a record of working with
people who disagree with her uh working
with
uh people who who have different
viewpoints and different objectives and
priorities and that's something she
would certainly take into the job if
she's confirmed and just one more
jed uh richard shelby has said he would
support the confirmation of shalonda
young what is your reaction to that is
she
a potential replacement should mira
tandon not
follow through well there's one nominee
to lead the budget department her name's
nira tandon
and that's who we're continuing to fight
for questions about shalonian
we're we're focused on fighting for the
person the president has nominated
one more follow-up on that has she
offered to withdraw her nomination yet
we are working in close touch with nira
and with nira tandon and with members of
congress on continuing to do the
outreach and engagement
uh to fight for her confirmation that's
where her focus is but no yes or no
whether she's offered to withdraw
that's not the stage we're in caitlyn
where the stage we're in is uh working
to
uh continue to fight for her nomination
and as you know it's a it's a numbers
game right it's a matter of getting
one republican to support her nomination
we're continuing to do that outreach
answer questions they have uh and
continue to reiterate her qualifications
and on the call with king salman that's
expected to happen you said you're still
working on scheduling it
does president biden want the saudi
crown prince to be
on that call uh the president's
intention as is the intention of this
government is to
uh to recalibrate our engagement with
saudi arabia and to have counterparts
communicate with counterparts and
uh print he communicated prince alman
communicated with the secretary of
defense that's the appropriate line
of communication and the president will
speak with the king at the appropriate
time it will be soon and as soon as we
have a
update on that being finalized and of
course when it happens we'll provide you
all with a readout i know that yeah
they'll be speaking but will he is he
okay if he's on the call
i would anticipate the call being
directly with the king and a one-on-one
call or a call of course you know it's
you know those would be the primary
participants okay my last question is on
the johnson and johnson vaccine as it's
moving toward authorization it looks
like
jeff zions the coordinator said today
they believe they're going down between
three and four million to ship
pending authorization that was initially
supposed to be much higher
according to the contract that they
johnson and johnson signed with the
federal government
closer to 10 million i believe in
february so is president biden
disappointed that johnson johnson is not
going to have
closer to 10 million vaccines ready to
go if
and when they get authorization well
caitlin
we were surprised to learn that john
cena johnson was behind
on their manufacturing as you noted it
was kind of reported earlier to be about
10 million and now it's more
like three to four million doses um that
uh they would be ready to ship
uh next week if they are moved through
the fda process which is not yet
concluded uh just to note and
we are going to continue to work with
them uh on
uh ensuring that um uh that
that can be expedited um so if if
they're if the
johnson johnson vaccine is approved
is that the extent of the calibration
just having the president deal directly
with king solomon
you say that mbs has been getting his
counterpart of the defense department
if the if the u.s government believes
that mohammed bin salman was
behind her in some way related to the
death of jamal khashoggi how can this
administration
continue to deal with it and in what way
do you intend
well i think we'll wait for the
unclassified report to be released which
will be released through the dni
and uh while i don't have an update on
that i expect that will be
soon uh to speak further and of course
uh as i when i talked about
recalibration i
uh was referring to of course the uh
counterpart to counterpart because that
was kind of how the question was posed
but you know we always look uh the
president is taking a fresh approach
to how he engages with foreign leaders
around the world and different from the
prior administration and that means he
will
not hold back and he will speak out when
there are concerns he has about
uh human rights abuses about uh
the lack of freedom of speech or the
lack of freedom of media and expression
or any concerns he has at the same time
we have a
long relationship with saudi arabia they
are being attacked in the region and
uh that is certainly an area where we
continue to work with them on but
i expect we'll have more to say uh when
we get post uh the release of that
report an
unrelated question um what is this
president's view toward
the loyalty that teachers unions should
have
towards students teacher this president
is a strong supporter of unions public
sector union
is the teacher's union's obligation to
the workers
and their concerns about safety or is
the teacher's union obligation
also to students well i can't speak to
the
obligations or the i'm not a
spokesperson for the teachers union i'm
a spokesperson for the president of the
united states so
i can convey to you that his commitment
is to the students
and to the teachers and to the parents
who want to have their kids back in
school
and he wants to do that safely and
that's what his focus is on and that's
the role he can play from the federal
government
good david all right uh just back on the
saudi
uh issue i understand that until you've
had the conversation you're not going to
talk much about the policy implications
president did have some things to say
during the campaign
he said we were in fact going to make
them pay a price
and uh make them uh in fact the pariah
that they are
and later he said there was little
social redeeming value in the present
government in saudi arabia
any reason to believe his view his
overall view of the saudis
saudi government as a pariah and little
redeeming social values
the president as you well know david
because you've probably been covering
him for a good chunk of this time has
had a long uh time he spent in the world
of foreign policy
and he is certainly uh familiar with uh
the the leadership in saudi arabia as he
is in the middle east in many parts of
the world and
i would certainly not say uh his
concerns or his views have changed
he is of course now president of the
united states and in that role
um he is not going to hold back as i
noted in speaking out when there are
concerns
of course he has the uh the right to
take action of any kind
um as the president of the united states
but there are also areas where we will
work
with the uh kingdom of saudi arabia on
including
uh ensuring that they have the
protections they need to face the
threats that are facing them
well a little more on this and following
on on
how you sort of think about this um
we have a pretty good idea what's in the
declassified report or
when it comes out because many elements
of it leaked two years ago when
when it was first first came out if you
come to the conclusion that there were
any senior saudi officials who were
involved in the khashoggi
murder would those officials be welcomed
in the united states
could they conceivably be subject to
criminal prosecution as
accessories to a murder and thus not
want to enter the united states
i certainly understand the line of
questioning and i know there's an
eagerness
for the full report to be released i'm
not going to get ahead of the policy
process
or the release of that report and you'll
have to come back
others will have to come back on the day
after it's just released and or the days
after and we can discuss it further
um go ahead oh sorry we'll come back to
you next time
go ahead thank you um a new york related
question for me
sure um i know you've been asked about
whether the president has confidence in
governor andrew cuomo given all the
controversy surrounding the nursing home
issues in new york
um during the pandemic but more broadly
i'd like to ask
if there are any lessons to be learned
here if the administration believes that
or has you know kicked off any
discussions in terms of
what type of role the federal government
should play in providing guidance
during an outbreak of a future
infectious disease
to nursing homes and whether there
should be some sort of
standardized data collection so that we
don't run into these issues with states
providing different
data at different times sure well it's a
it's um i think there are a lot of
lessons learned
um from what we've gone through as a
country over the last year and as
you know uh new york is one of the
hardest hit states
in the country and earliest states hit
hard in
the country was kind of on the front
lines of that
and the challenges that came up you know
i will say that
our focus at this point in time is on
working with
governors from across the country from
red states and blue states
and working with them to ensure we can
take the steps now
to increase vaccines that are being
distributed to states is
yesterday we announced another increase
in that to
an over 70 percent increase since the
president took office to increasing
communication
to increasing the number of vaccination
sites that are on the ground
there's going to be plenty of time to
look back there will be many lessons
learned
but right now we are still in the midst
of the crisis and we need to keep our
resources and our focus
on saving more lives uh go ahead
uh thanks jen did the white house any
white house officials reach out to some
of those ceos who signed the letter was
there any communications ahead of that
letter
well the letter was put together by a
group from the outs or a couple of
groups i should say from the outside
business board i think was one of them
and there were a couple of other
organizations
we of course engaged with business
groups and business leaders
all the time but it was not put together
as put together by these outside groups
did the white house specifically
attracted any of them any of the ceos
before they signed the letter and to
encourage them to sign the letter
i know it was put out by other groups
but just wondering why we didn't play an
organizational
role here as i understand it it was done
by these outside groups
um but we of course engage with business
leaders all the time
so um you know i don't know that i have
more specifics to lay out
you're a tandon has the white house
specifically talked to bernie's
senator bernie sanders or senator
kristen cinema about the viability
have they talked to them today about
what what's going to happen going
forward
about the viability of her nomination
correct we
have been engaged i noted yesterday and
i don't have a new number update that
nero tandon herself had engaged directly
with 44
senators we've also engaged with many
more far beyond that democrats and
republicans
some of them have been over the last
three days some of them were before that
uh some of them have been
repeats um but we don't we're not going
to read out the individual conversations
from here obviously any senator can
speak to
our engagement from their platform if
they choose to
oh go ahead thank you jeff we spoke
yesterday
about immigration and this facility
hhs facility in carrizo springs texas
for migrant children and you said
it is not kids in cages we've seen some
photos now
of containers is there a better
description is it kids in containers
instead of kids in cages
what is the the white house's
description of this facility
well let me let me give a broader
description of what's happening here
we have a number of unaccompanied minors
children who are coming into the country
without their families
what we are not doing what the last
administration did
was separate those kids rip them from
the arms of their parents
at the border we are not doing that that
is immoral and that is not the approach
of this administration
these kids we have a couple of options
we can send them back home
and do a dangerous journey back we are
not doing that either that is also
putting them at risk we can quickly
transfer them
from cbp to these hhs run facilities
that's one option or we can put them
with families and sponsors without any
vetting
there were some problems that that that
that process ran into as well
we've chosen the middle option and these
hhs
facilities this is one of them you're
referring to we had to expand and open
additional facilities
because there was not enough space in
the existing facilities
and if we were to abide by covid
protocols that's the process and the
step
this facility in texas which has been
reopened
has been revamped has been there are
teachers
there is medical facilities and our
objective is to move them
move these kids quickly from there to
vetted
sponsored families uh and to places
where they can
safely be this is a difficult situation
it's a difficult choice that's the
choice we've made so
just one step back from that we've been
talking to people down at the border who
say that
right now dhs and the border patrol are
using the same
kind of facilities now that they did
during the trump administration and that
there's a facility right now it's in
donna texas instead of mcallen texas but
it's
tents and chain-link fence around it and
so
a cbp facility before they're
transferred to the hhs facility is that
what you're referring to
yes and the issue would be that just in
the last couple days
they had hundreds of kids that they were
holding for over 72 hours which is the
legal limit
to keep somebody in a temporary facility
so i'm just curious why let's
let's be clear though because i know you
want to be clear with the public
about the differences the cbp facilities
which you're right
the objective is to is to move kids
unaccompanied minors as quickly as
possible
under 72 hours to these hhs
fund-sponsored facilities which
is the one where we've been referring to
in texas they are two different things
there has been some there were some
delays last week because of weather and
because some of these facilities to
safely move these kids to
did not have power and were not in a
place where they could
they had the capacity to take in these
kids and do it safely
that is not our objective that is not
our goal so some
unfortunately did stay four days five
days or longer
but the objective is to move them as
quickly as possible to the hhs sponsored
facilities
has the white house seen the comment
from alexandria ocasio-cortez who
uh speaking about that hhs facility in
carrico springs said this is not okay
never has been okay never will be okay
no matter the administration or party
well i think the difficulty is i haven't
seen the full context of the
quote or interview of the of the tweet
uh that was that she shared
but i would say the difficulty is what i
outlined or what i outlined earlier
we have kids coming across the border it
is heartbreaking
i think we all as human beings are
heartbroken as parents as mothers as
fathers too we only have a couple of
choices
what we are not doing is dividing these
kids and separating from their parents
at the border which is what the last
administration did
and why president biden or then
candidate biden and then candidate
harris
were outspoken at the time about these
kids being pulled from their parents
what we are doing is working as quickly
as possible
to process these kids into these hhs
facilities
which have been revamped which have
medical and educational services
available
so that we can then transfer them to
families that's what our approach is
and so if there is this big difference
would the administration
support if it could be done but safely
because of covet and with privacy
concerns for the children in mind would
the
administration support letting reporters
in and president to see
what the difference is i think you'd
have to talk to the
department of homeland security about
that there are obviously safety
protocols about that
privacy concerns but i certainly
encourage you to reach out about that
uh go ahead in the back uh totally
different texas questions
sure um about the president's visit on
friday
so the president's infrastructure plan
uh includes a promise to
quote modernize the nation's electric
grid making it smarter and more
resilient
can that be done without federal
oversight of the texas grid which
we all got a reminder is not under
federal oversight
uh you're right and some parts of texas
are on the tech are on the federal grid
as as you well know as somebody who
knows a lot about texas uh
look i think there's going to be a lot
of time in the future to have a
discussion and debate about what weather
weatherization what preparation should
have been taken in advance
we're not going to have that debate
today we're not going to have that
debate on friday
the president is going to texas because
he wants to show his support
because he wants to survey the damage on
the ground see how people are impacted
see how he can tap into additional
resources in the federal government
as you know and as i noted at the top
texas is still in a state of emergency
there are millions of people who are
impacted
we can have a policy debate later right
now we're going to help the people who
are still suffering and going through
a really challenging time does the
president consider what happened in
texas last week and his
you know we still have the after effects
does he consider that to be a natural
disaster
or a man-made disaster and how does that
affect the policy response
well again there'll be a policy
discussion and i'm sure
as we look ahead to delivering on the
president's build back better agenda as
you know he's been a long long-time fan
of infrastructure he loves
infrastructure
it's one of the things that i'm sure
we'll be talking about in the months
ahead
uh but uh and protecting our nation's
critical infrastructure which we all
know is
outdated but we're not going to put new
labels on it today we're just going to
focus on how we make sure people have
drinking water how people have uh you
know
not in the cold how families have a
place to live and
we will have plenty of time to have a
policy debate
follow-ups on this any significance to
picking houston
is the place to go significant for the
fact that it's ted cruz's hometown for
instance
any other significance that is not a
significance i would say that we
uh while the president is there he
wanted to also visit a vaccine
a place where vaccines are being
distributed
so that was another component of the
trip in addition we worked in very close
coordination as i've noted as we were
trying to figure out the timing of the
trip with
experts on the ground with our acting
fema administrator on where it would be
most appropriate to visit
and you may have sort of already
addressed this but i just want to be
clear
can we expect any sort of announcement
while the president is in texas or going
to texas
investigations new aid deliverables
anything
uh we've been kind of reviewing every
day new assistants that can be
distributed which i've been trying to
read out at the top of the briefing
in coordination with our uh acting fema
administrator and
alicia wood randall uh so i don't know
it may be that there may be more because
we're just trying to get as much out the
door as possible but
um i i wouldn't expect uh i wouldn't ex
there's nothing that we're holding i
should say for friday
that makes sense go ahead hi jen uh one
for me and then uh
i'm the pooler today so one for my
colleagues okay um
what's the white house view on this uh
this variant that's emerged from
california and how it might uh factor
into
uh your modeling on a timetable for
normalcy and your vaccination campaign
sure well one of the reasons we've been
quite careful uh
or i have tried to be about predicting a
return to normalcy is because there
are unpredictable components of the
things that come up with the virus right
as we've seen with
other variants and certainly the
california varian is an example of that
the reporting on this is quite new as
you know in our health and medical
experts we'll of course
take a close look at it and make some
evaluations about what they foresee the
impact
as being so i would certainly defer to
them on that on that perspective and and
and send you to them to ask any health
questions and has the president been
briefed specifically on the california
variant and is he concerned
alarm the president is briefed regularly
on kovid he asks questions about covet
and updates and i would
not be surprised if he had not asked uh
this morning
i was not in any policy meetings with
him this morning so i don't have any
update on his briefings
so uh from my colleagues outside the
room i actually received several
different questions
sure go ahead on some of the saudi
uh call with the saudi uh king salman as
well as the construction
report and i know you've addressed this
but is it important for the president
to speak with the king in the context of
the release of the report
i'm not going to preview his call with
the king obviously they'll cover a range
of topics
and when we have concluded that call i'm
sure we'll provide a
a readout to all of you good
yeah just a quick follow on the tendon
nomination sure we were told that
senator sanders wasn't
consulted at all before you guys
announced her nomination
and i just want to ask why didn't
sanders get a heads up on
uh we consult i mean the process and
having worked on the confirmations team
i can give you a little insight onto
this um the process uh during the
transition of
nominees being selected uh you know
they're often
was consultation with a limited number
of members it usually typically wasn't
very broad in advance of a selection
obviously the president selects people
he's going to
nominate for positions and then
oftentimes the immediate follow-up to an
announcement is
immediate outreach from the nominees to
a range of senators and a range of
uh officials in congress so that's a
normal part of the process
budget though so is there any reason why
he wasn't given a heads-up
again i don't think i can speak to you
know her announcement or who was or
wasn't consulted in the days ahead
from several months ago but senator
sanders is someone who
uh we consult with regularly at many
levels including at the president's
level and
expect we'll work with him on
confirmations but also a range of the
president's objectives
it's a good follow on immigration some
house and senate democrats have raised
the possibility of putting
a pathway for undocumented essential
workers
into a second reconciliation package
pelosi even said it would be wonderful
if it could fit
does the president support that option
i'm sure he'll have
discussions and consultations with
speaker pelosi as he does frequently and
others about
how they want to move the path forward
on
immigration and he proposed the the
comprehensive bill with several
components because he thinks they all
are pivotal um but uh you know we'll
have we haven't had
any extensive conversations on that yet
so i don't have anything to read out for
you and reconciliation
again you haven't had no we'll we'll see
we'll we'll let congress play out the
process of what they want to propose or
how they want to work through the
components of
the immigration package he's proposed it
in a as a full
multi-step comprehensive uh package
because he feels that
smart security a pathway to citizenship
and addressing the root causes are all
pivotal but we expect this to be an
ongoing conversation about different
components of
what members support then if i could
just one more i mean as you know the ui
benefits
uh expire march 14. is there a backup
plan if the profit package doesn't
pass congress by that time uh well let
me first say that
um that um you know the president
uh is focused on moving this forward as
quickly as possible because as you noted
uh there is a timeline um in the middle
of march when millions of people
would you lose their benefits and it's
not everybody on that day
and it's it's there's a progression of
it but that is of great concern
and that is one of the reasons why there
is significant urgency in moving this
forward as quickly as possible
and as you also know covering congress
um you know a backup plan
most scenarios would involve congress
this is the best pathway to preventing
uh millions of people from losing uh
their benefits and that's why we are
hopeful that it will move quickly
through the house as we anticipate it
will and then quickly through the senate
and we'll be able to
uh get the rescue plan signed into law
so that that is not an issue
thank you thank you jen i have two
questions on iran and yemen
on iran the president opted for
diplomacy
but there's words in the region in
europe as well that the ballistic
missile
development and iran's interference in
the region
might not be addressed or linked to the
nuclear power can you assure us that
actually this is the case and second do
you believe that iran is testing you
resolved
in iraq by attacking the green zones and
the alveolar
airport recently well
first uh on the first question can you
just say the last part of it again you
were saying i'm sorry masks make it
difficult
you guys gonna link the ballistic
missiles development and iran's
interference
in for arab countries to the nuclear
file or are you guys
leave it separately because there are
warriors that actually are very eager to
secure a deal and you're going to
leave this behind like it happened in
2015.
well first the president's iran is a
long way from compliance
as you well know from covering this
issue quite closely
uh and the president has been clear that
if iran comes back into full compliance
with its obligations
we will do the same and of course then
use that as a platform to
build a longer and stronger agreement
including addressing
ballistic missiles and many of the
concerns that as you noted
countries in the region our european
partners have
about the actions of iran but we are
not at that point the point we are at is
that uh the united states
has expressed an openness to an
invitation to have a diplomatic
conversation
uh that's the stage we are at as you
know we have not taken any steps
to uh roll back on sanctions or to
provide i should say
sanctions relief as has been requested
uh and we are
in a place where we're waiting to see uh
if iran will uh
you know what their response will be to
the europeans invitation so why are you
not responding to the attacks in iraq
and elsewhere
the attacks in iran uh well the attacks
in iraq
um i should say well first we have not
made a final
uh attribution um of uh but
of the attacks uh we will i will say as
you know the president spoke with the
prime minister
uh last night they this was an extensive
part of the conversation
we do hold iran accountable for the
actions of their proxies
and of course uh we reserve the right to
respond in a manner
and at a time of our choosing but we
will respond in a way that's calculated
on our time
timetable and using a mix of tools seen
in unseen
what we will not do and what we've seen
in the past is lash out and risk and
escalation
that plays into the hands of iran by
further destabilizing iraq and that is
our priority
and if i may on yemen since you enlist
the houthis as a terrorist organization
do you believe that the humanitarian
situation has improved
considering that now they are trying to
take me around which is a
big city um and some say that they've
been emboldened
by lifting them from the terror list
yes and as you know um our our
our issue has never been with the people
of yemen right uh and
certainly the humanitarian situation has
been a long time concern i don't have an
assessment of the
the humanitarian situation on the ground
i the state department is likely going
to have the best assessment of that but
um i can also talk to them or you can of
course reach out to them directly to get
an assessment
go in the back i think strength two
quick questions if you don't mind
first on voting rights we're seeing
several states consider bills to
restrict
voting rights or restrict voting is the
administration willing to work with
congress to pass legislation to expand
access to voting certainly expanding
access to voting making it easier for
people to vote
is a priority of the president's a
priority of the vice presidents and
we're happy to have that conversation
in what place would be would you be
willing to do so and
the democrats have sent a letter to the
president asking for policing of
voting related crimes is that something
that the administration is going to look
into
and what are other specific steps that
the administration is willing to do
to help combat some of these these
pieces of legislation that we're seeing
in other states i have not taken
a full look at all the different pieces
of legislation i'm happy to talk to
ambassador rice who's
running points on this and i expect
we'll have more to say on voting rights
soon
uh but let me do that and we can see if
we can get you more specifics after the
briefing and then shifting gears i know
that you have talked about supporting
a study of reparations but on another
note we've talked about the
impact that pivot has had on the black
community whether it's
in deaths in the job losses yeah is the
administration considering some type of
targeted relief for black communities or
communities that have been hit hard that
may not be reparations but maybe
job training or something to help
communities build back
from this pandemic specifically
communities that have been hit hard such
as black community
sure well let me first say that the
american rescue
plan is the package that we hope we will
have signed into law
soon that is going to provide relief
that is targeted at the communities and
the people and the families who have
been hardest hit
from direct checks and payments to more
money for vaccinations to get them out
to communities that have been
harder hits to the reopening of schools
that is certainly impacting
many many communities including black
communities
beyond that uh obviously the president
uh
will consider a range of options things
that he talked about on the campaign
trail
to build the economy back better uh
that's not anything we have to preview
or that's been finalized at this point
in time but
our objective right now is to get the
american rescue plan passed and to get
that direct relief out to a range of
communities
and i understand 1400 100 checks are one
thing but i guess
down the road helping communities people
that have lost their jobs training them
for these jobs of the future
is that something again job retraining
helping the manufacturing sector
uh doing better with caregiving uh
improving improving our nation's
infrastructure these are all components
of the president's agenda that he talked
about on the campaign trail and
is certainly a blueprint for what he
would like to do as president
but right now we're just focused on the
rescue plan getting it passed
getting it through getting that direct
relief out and then i expect we'll have
more to say he will have more to say
after that is concluded go ahead
on the minimum wage sure one of the
points of debate
as it relates to the president's covert
relief package
would the president support anything
below
15 for example the proposal for an 11
minimum wage uh the president put
15 minimum wage an increase in his
package because that's what he believes
the increase
should be uh as you know is working its
way through a parliamentary process at
this point in time
hopefully we'll have more news on that
um in the coming days uh
and uh but his support is for the 15
increase senator sanders has said
there's no room for compromise does the
president think there's room for
compromise on that 15
well the compromise will be between
members of the senate who may have
disagreement
on where the minimum wage should sit and
what the process should be
but the first step is the bird rule the
bird bath i just like to say that every
day
and then members will and we're
certainly hopeful that that will
conclude with the minimum wage being
included in there but that is up to the
parliamentarian
for that process to conclude and then
senators will have to debate what a
final package looks like
just a quick one um there's been some
survey data that suggests there's a
hesitancy
within the armed services of taking a
vaccine
the commander-in-chief in theory could
require
that members of the military take
vaccines that's something he's
considered doing and is
is wanting or willing to do that's a
really interesting question
everyone's questions are interesting but
that's a very interesting question uh
i have not spoken with him about that or
to secretary austin about that who any
decision like that would be in
consultation and
at his recommendation uh i'm happy to
follow up with it on it or i would i
would suggest
you talk to my old friend john kirby
about where they stand on that question
go ahead
david just following up on kirsten's on
the minimum wage
um there it sounds from your description
of
the negotiation underway now between
house and senate
on that on awarding the president would
basically
sign whatever comes out of conference
here that would be the implication of
your
your statement that he doesn't really
have a choice on the minimum wage
at this point is that what you meant to
say that that is not my implication i
hope that's not what other people took
from what i said
but what i was conveying is that there's
a process that this has to undergo and
it
needs to move through the parliament
senate parliamentary process we don't
even know where they're going to
conclude and whether the minimum wage is
in the package or not in the package
and certainly and i'll leave the
analysis to all of you there would be
many who would
support it not being in the package and
there would be many who would oppose it
not being in the package
we understand that we know how bill
becomes the law what i'm conveying is
we're not going to get ahead of that
process
and then you're not saying the president
won't sign it if it doesn't have a
minimum wage
i think we are not even at the stage the
president proposed an increase in the
minimum wage in his package that's what
he wants to be in the final package he
also was in the center for 36 years and
has great respect for the parliamentary
process
we're going to see that through once
that's concluded we can all talk further
about the next steps
go ahead there's a report that south
korea is working with iran to
possibly unfreeze seven billion dollars
in iranian money
but they would need a waiver from the
u.s state department is that something
that the administration would consider
i i've not seen those reports i'm happy
to follow up with our team at the state
department but
it'd probably be more direct if you
follow up with them directly okay and
one more
on vaccines i what does the white house
think when they see
a governor like the democratic governor
of connecticut ned lamont who says he
thinks if he goes his own way not with
the national recommendations
to distribute vaccines just based on
age then you can get them out faster and
more
equitably than if he follows the
recommendations from the federal level
well
we make recommendations at the federal
level for a reason because
there are groups that we feel should be
prioritized
whether they're frontline workers
healthcare workers individuals over a
certain age
as you noted and our objective of course
is to get to the stage where there's
recommendations for people who are much
younger who don't have pre
you know health conditions that would uh
mean they would qualify
um so that's what that's the reason we
laid them out as we do obviously
governors
make different choices about the
prioritization and the prioritization
order but we stand by the guidelines
we've recommended at a national level
thanks everyone
you